بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على رسوله الكريم وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله الا
الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
صلى الله عليه وسلم
مهاجرين
قريش
‏from all now how compion
before we
comp and compion
حديث
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏entir
and even before is with him also
ابو حم الرازي رحمه الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم حج
حج
جره
حج صلى الله عليه وسلم
رضي الله عنه سعد بن ابي وقاس
سعد بن ابي وقاس صلى الله عليه وسلم
سعد بن ابي وقاس
في سبيل
‏was
of the
مسلم
ابي وقاس
الله عنه
عمر رضي الله
خفه
رضي الله عنه
سعد
[Silence]
‏di
صلى الله عليه وسلم
جاءني رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
يعودني عام حجه الوداع
مع وجع اشتد بي
فقلت يا رسول الله اني قد بلغ بي من الوجع
ما
وانا ذو مال
ولا يرثني الا ابنه لي افاتصدق بثلثي مالي
ف حين حجه الوداع
وتوفي
سنه 55 بعد الهجره
حجه الوداع
سنه تسع في اواخر سنه تسع
في حجه الوداع
كانت له ابنه واحده
فقط ليس له الا ابنه
ترثه ليس له من البنين شيء وليس له من
الاولاد شيء الا هذه البنت وكان ذا مال
يعني كان غنيا ثريا
سعد رضي الله عنه
ذات محمد صلى الله عليه
حج
حج صلى الله عليه وسلم
was
that was
death
‏And so the prophet
came to visit him.
سعد was veryalthy man
at this point
yeared
more0 yearsent
was die ander
and
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ander
my air air to my fortune so shall i not
give her a third and
give the remaining two thirds in
charityingthd
of my fortune
and so the حافظ صلى الله عليه وسلم ساد
لا نو
قلت فالشطر يا رسول الله الشطر يعني النصف
الشطر النصف وقد يراد به ما يقارب النصف
وقد يراد به منتصف الشيء اذا كان في مجال
الجهات فولي وجهك شطر المسجد الحرام يعني
نحوه
‏He said what about a third
shall I not give away third prop صلى
الله عليه وسلم said no and so what about
half of my fortune قال
فثلث يا رسول الله
قال الثلث والثلث كثير او كبير في بعض
الروايات
يعني الثلث حقك لكن ليس الافضل
لكن ليس الافضل هذا ما يفهم من هذه الصيغه
الثلث يعني لك الثلث هذا اليك والثلث كثير
فعندنا الاسلام والايمان والاحسان
الاسلام الثلث
الايمان
الربع
الاحسان
الخمس وهو الذي وهو الذي كان يامر به ابو
بكر رضي الله عنه في خلافته
بعض الناس قد يتعجب من هذا الشيءقول
هذه صدقه نعم لكن من اولى الناس بصدقتك
هم عيالك واهل بيتك واقاربك
بعض الناس
قد يظن ان ايتاء ذي القربى من الصدقه
يوهن من اجل الصدقه
وليس الامر كذلك بل هم اولى الناس باحسانك
‏And so
what about
my
solary have
is acceptable but still aot
a third is acceptable but still a lot
meaning
[Silence]
‏ondes
away more
in will more third is not to
[Silence]
اني جاعل في الارض خليفه
‏another
resources one another in stat
inysical traits financial standing etc
and so thisalth no longer belongs to me
as soon as a person falls enough
to be on
the
‏and
more
[Silence]
ابو بكر الصديق رضي الله عنه
الغنيمه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ابو بكر الصديق
الا يرضى العبد بما رضي الله لنفسه
[Silence]
‏amors
this is ch that be him and the and
of his
leaving behind upon his death bed. ‏We
have this idea
in our culture which
got from western cultures from nonmlim
cultures from cultures
made up of
ideologies not incorporating belief in
Allah in the last day in which my money
is m it belongs to me I earned
‏my body
can
ultraalism
kind
of all lically fl of all this has
nothing to do with a into the
and so youl say to their for you will
you will
الله سبحانه وى
[Silence]
‏I can write
into myerica
more often a lot of people think right
this is not part of Islam at all this is
actually considered to be a major sin in
islam rather
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
expectation
ان شاء الله والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين وجزاكم الله خيرا